>> Sean: THIS IS A FOX NEW
ALERT.
BREAKING NEWS OUT OF TEXAS.
TWO INMATES BELIEVED TO BE MS-13
GANG MEMBERS WERE KILLED AT A
FEDERAL PENITENTIARY IN
BEAUMONT, PROMPTING A NATIONWIDE
LOCKDOWN FOR THE ENTIRE FEDERAL
PRISON SYSTEM.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THIS STORY.
BIDEN'S BOARD OR NEGLECT IS
GETTING WORSE BY THE SECOND, AS
THE PRESIDENT TODAY CLAIMED THAT
ALL WE NEED TO DISSOLVE THE
BORDER CRISIS IS FIGURE OUT WHY
DO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COME HERE
THE FIRST PLACE?
ARE YOU REALLY THAT DUMB, JOE?
IT GETS WORSE BECAUSE WE HAVE
MORE EVIDENCE OF GROWING
TENSIONS INSIDE THE BORDER
PATROL AMID THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ZOLLO DISREGARD
FOR THE RULE OF LAW, AIDING AND
ABETTING LAWBREAKING.
LISTEN TO TS EXCHANGEETWEEN
THE BORDER CHIEF AND CHIEF AND
RANK-AND-FILE STANDING UP TO HIM
LAST WEEKN LAREDO, TEXAS, AS
THE FAILED DHS SECRETARY,
MAYORKAS, VISITED THE AREA.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU COME TO WORK.
YOU UPSET BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T GET
THE DESIRED OUTCOME THAT YOU
WANT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU GIVE
UP.
I KNOW YOU'RE NOT.
THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING.
WE DON'T GIVE UP.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS JOB.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> I CAN'T HEAR YOU.
>> FOR EVIL TO TRIUMPH, GOOD MEN
DO NOTHING.
>> Sean: WOW.
HERE WITHEACTION, LEO 2.0
TERRELL ALONG WITH AMERICA FIRST
LEGAL FOUNDER STEPHEN MILLER
DOING SOME GREAT WORK WITH HIS
LEGAL FIRM.
LEO, STARTING WITH YOU.
THAT NEVER HAPPENS WHERE AN
AGENT WILL STAND UP TO A CHIEF,
A BOSS LIKE THAT, AND BE THAT
BOLD IN THAT BLUNT.
BUT IT REALLY WAS WARRANTED.
>> IT WAS NECESSARY BECAUSE
THERE'S A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BETWEEN
OPEN BORDERS AND THE BORDER
RANK-AND-FILE OFFICERS WHO
SIGNED UP TO CONTROL THE BORDER
AND PREVENT ILLEGAL ALIENS FROM
COMING IN.
THEY, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
HAVE TURNED THE BORDER OFFICERS
INTO TRAVEL AGENTS.
THEY HAVE BASICALLY NOW
ACCOMMODATING CRIMINALS TO
DESIGNATE THEM TO ANY PLACE IN
AFE COUNTRY.
ND